Do you need to take clear dim, so far as I'm and aroma clear?
Well, there's certainly some cross, there's nutrients in clear dim
that are, clear dim does have some, some of the things in it
that each one of these have, but the concentration of the
broco products in so far as I've is the greatest, you know, you
don't get the same amount in the clear dim or the aroma
clear, I don't think there's any of this or a more aside, broccoli
products in aroma clear, and you don't get the I3C in the clear
dim that you get in the aroma clear. So there's, there's, yeah,
there's benefit to take it all three of them. If you're trying to cut down
on products, certainly we could do another cheek swab and test that. I was
ER positive or two negative, so be ER positive. That's why you
definitely want to be taking these types of products.